as joe biden prepares his team the media
can't help but drool
the culture wars continue and deepen as
the left feels its own and democrats try
to grab control of the us senate i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
i protect my data with a vpn
so should you visit expressvpn.com ben
we're gonna get to all the news of the
day in just
one second first let's talk about that
cell phone bill so you've been spending
way too much money
on your cell phone bill i know this
because i used to spend way too much
money on my cell phone
bill as well well now i use pure talk
usa and so
should you pure talk usa it's a
veteran-run wireless company think at t
but much better they understand what it
means to serve
verizon at t t-mobile if you're with
them you're overpaying pure and simple
puretalk can easily save you over 400
a year listen here's what you need
unlimited talk text and two gigs of data
not unlimited data two gigs of data
for just 20 bucks a month if you go over
on that data usage they don't charge you
for it so why would you be paying for
unlimited data when you need two gigs
and if you go over that and they still
don't charge you pure talk
is easy it's the easiest decision you
will make today you can keep your phone
and your number or get great deals on
the latest iphones and androids
as well many phone companies will try to
intentionally confuse you about what it
is
that is in your phone package that's so
they can up charge you instead grab your
mobile phone sell pound 250 and say
ben shapiro when you do you'll save 50
off your first month
style pounds 2 5 0 say keyword ben
shapiro to get started
pure talk is simply smarter wireless
style pound two five zero say keyword
ben
shapiro two get started okay so
the media just they couldn't wait for
this moment they couldn't wait for the
moment when they could begin
treating joe biden as the
president-elect of the united states now
as we have said many times formally he
is not president-elect of the united
states until december 14th
on a legal level trump has still
lawsuits outgoing the chances that he's
gonna win those lawsuits are of course
very low right now given the evidence
that we have before us but the media
couldn't wait for this they couldn't
wait for it and this is what created
trump in the first place is the fact
that your media the people who are
supposed to bring you truth
the people who are supposed to be
objective all they are good for
is cheering on democrats all they are
good for is sneering at you
sneering at your priorities sneering at
your policy preferences
sneering at you personally this is what
your objective media do
and they made quan during the trump
administration they made bank during the
trump administration
playing this little game where they
pretended to be objective while
characterizing you as a deplorable and
characterizing
trump as an evil orange hitlerian piece
of crap
right this is how they made their money
if you look at the subscription numbers
on the new york times and the washington
post they skyrocketed why because they
were doing fan service
to a liberal audience that is what they
are for and now they're gonna go right
back
to that fan service they're gonna go
right back to it
okay so yesterday the dow jones
industrial average reached
30 000. the media immediately began
trumpeting this because this was
evidence that the markets love
joe biden or alternatively this is
evidence that the
markets are kind of happy with status
quo and they understand that joe biden
is unlikely to be able to do anything
given the fact that congress is likely
to be republican or at least the senate
is likely to be republican
and so president trump came out for
about 60 seconds and he announced that
the stock market had reached 30 000. now
five seconds ago when trump talked about
the stock market the entire media
laughed at him the entire media
suggested the stock market is not a good
reflection
of how americans think kamala harris set
an open debate the stock market doesn't
matter
because 50 of americans don't have money
in the stock market but now
the media were all out there chomping at
the bit to try and credit joe biden with
the increase
in the stock market by the way what
worthy of note when the stock market
jumped after the last election
the media tried to credit it to barack
obama instead of to donald trump so you
see how the game works when a republican
takes office
any stock market growth is the result of
the democratic predecessor when a
democrat is supposedly elected then that
democrat
immediately is credited with all gains
in the stock market when a republican is
in charge and the stock market is going
up the stock market doesn't matter only
rich people care about the stock market
not true by the way there are plenty of
people who have money in 401ks and that
401k is invested in stocks and bonds
okay but
president trump comes out and he says
look at that the stock market's over 30
000 the media mock him mercilessly for
it here's president trump yesterday
the stock market's just broken thirty
thousand never been broken that number
that's a sacred number thirty thousand
nobody thought they'd ever see it
uh that's the ninth time since uh
the beginning of 2020 and it's the 48th
time
that we've broken records in during
the trump administration and i just want
to congratulate all the people within
the administration
that work so hard and most importantly i
want to
congratulate the people of our country
because there are no people like you
okay now let's be very very clear what
exactly happened with the stock market
here what happened is that the stock
market does not like uncertainty
the stock market hates new information
when when there is a vast
change upon the land the stock market
absolutely hates it
okay so if democrats had taken the
senate the stock market would not have
jumped the same way if there had been no
coronavirus vaccine
being developed the stock market would
still be in the doldrums in the last
three weeks we've had news that
republicans are likely to keep the
senate and we've had news
that the that the biden administration
when it comes in if it comes in in
january is likely to pick janet yellen
who's a long-time federal reserve
insider right jerome powell was not
really very different from janet yellen
in terms of governance
and we also know that these vaccines are
on their way so the stock market is
pricing that it's not the stock market
loves it joe biden
and it's not the stock market dislikes
donald trump after all the stock market
continued to rise radically under
president trump doesn't matter the media
credit biden with this thing because the
media cannot wait to attribute every
good thing to a democrat
and every bad thing to a republican
here's how the new york times reported
this
stux on wall street rallied to records
on tuesday as key states
certified joe biden's victory in the
presidential election and news that
janet yellen will be the next treasury
secretary raised expectations
for a big push of government spending to
aid the economy now do you think it's
more about
biden or do you think it's more about
him not selecting say elizabeth warren
for his secretary of the treasury which
is a real possibility
the growth expectations were bolstered
by late news late on monday that yellen
the former chair of the federal reserve
and proponents of government
intervention in the economy is biden's
pick for treasury secretary
yellen said in october the economy
needed extraordinary fiscal support
during the pandemic
after two decades at the central bank
analysts say she'd be able to foster a
close relationship between the two
institutions
okay now again this has very little to
do with biden because jerome powell
who's running
the federal reserve pretty similar to
janet yellen and steve mnuchin who's the
treasury secretary is basically a
democrat i mean steve mnuchin
was a lifelong democrat actually until
trump selected him for his cabinet
and steve mnuchin was happy to spend
oodles and oodles of money so nothing
really
changed that doesn't matter the media
have to pretend that this is joe biden's
stock market rally
and that the stock stock market matters
again right so the media are just on
board
with all this they're here for it man
they are so excited they're also excited
about joe biden's cabinet picks we're
gonna get to those crappy cabinet pics
in
just one second because they really are
pretty garbage first
we hear the stories in the news all the
time you hear somebody has to defend
their family god forbid they have to use
a firearm
and then they get arrested because they
didn't know the law well
right they end up in the middle of the
legal process well this is why it's
important that if you own a firearm or
if you intend on owning a firearm you
know how to use it you know when to use
it and you have the legal defense
necessary in case god forbid you have to
use it
in your own defense this is why you need
the us concealed carry association
the us concealed concealed carry
association will give you the complete
concealed carry and family defense guide
and it is 100 free in it you will learn
how to detect attackers before they see
you how to survive the mass shooting the
safest and most dangerous places to sit
in a restaurant how to responsibly own
and store a gun
especially if you have little kids and a
whole lot more it's a 164-page guide it
is loaded with valuable information just
just text my name ben
to 87222 and you get instant access and
a chance to win a thousand bucks
so you can buy a gun to protect your
family tech spend to 87
222 right now join my friends over at
the uscca they have indispensable
resources for gun owners and would-be
gun owners get instant access to that
complete concealed carrying family
defense guide for free
and a chance to win a thousand bucks by
texting ben to 87
222 87 222 okay so
joe biden's picks first cabinet are
indeed all part of the
foreign policy blob as it is called in
washington dc a group of supposed
intellectuals and pseudo-intellectuals
who've been wrong about every major
foreign policy issue
of their lifetimes but speak in honeydew
tones you've got tony blinken over at
secretary of state
who has spent the last couple of decades
being wrong about everything from
injecting american troops into syria to
the iran deal which he says was just a
godsend a wonderful godsend
jake sullivan over a national security
adviser spot
who spent the last few years talking
about the evils of trump pulling out of
the iran deal
by the way a move that precipitated the
rise of an alliance in the middle in the
middle east that spans now
all the way from india to greece
essentially against the iranian threat
and you've got the foreign policy blob
of john kerry the former secretary of
state under barack obama was secretary
of state in american history
he will be back as a climate envoy which
means that joe biden is serious about
climate change and the media are there
for that
as well so yesterday kamala harris did a
did a presentation
biden and kamala harris did a
presentation of all of the members of
the new cabinet
and it was like a bizarre awards show
for career bureaucrats who suck at their
jobs
it was really incredible it's like the
oscars for
foreign policy mush minds here is kamala
harris talking about we selected a
cabinet that looks like america then you
look behind her and she's a bunch of
white dudes here's kamala harris
when joe asked me to be his running mate
he told me about his commitment
to making sure we selected a cabinet
that looks like america
that reflects the best of our nation
and that's what we have done today's
nominees and appointees come from
different places
they bring a range of different life and
professional experiences
and perspectives and they also share
something else in common an
unwavering belief in america's
ideals an unshakable commitment
to democracy human rights
and the rule of law uh no not no
actually they they all share experience
in the obama administration where they
drone civilians
uh they also share an unshakable
commitment to priorities on foreign
policy including
the cutting of the american military
they also share
i love when she's like they have such
different backgrounds they all went to
ivy league schools
right they all think exactly the same on
foreign policy and there is very little
dissent
in that particular room so that's okay i
went to ivy league schools too i don't
mind people who go to ivy league schools
that's fine
my problem is when she suggests it's
diversity of viewpoints what she
actually means is behind me
i have a person who's hispanic and i
also have like one person maybe who's
black
and everybody else is a white dude who
knew joe biden since like 1980.
isn't that exciting guys super super
exciting stuff among them
john kerry so john kerry gets up and he
says he's going to work on climate
change after his
wonderful work in ensuring that the
iranian government was strengthened
in pursuit of regional terrorism he is
now going to work on climate
which is a pretty good guarantee that
we're all going to boil to death as the
world heats because john kerry has been
unsuccessful
at everything he has ever tried because
he is a garbage person he's a garbage
person and a garbage politician
and here he is now being brought back
again for another role
this time to presumably quash american
economic growth
in the name of ridiculous solutions that
are not solutions so he can pretend to
have solved climate change when in fact
he will not have solved
climate change fracking a thing that
democrats hate has done more to reduce
carbon emissions in the united states
than any single policy any of these
democrats will ever propose bar none
anyway here is john kerry talking about
how he believes in science
and god no
no he does not john carrigan
57 years ago this week
joe biden and i were college kids
when we lost the president who inspired
both of us
to try to make a difference a president
who reminded us
that here on earth god's work must truly
be our
own president joe biden
will trust in god and he will also
trust in science to guide our work on
earth
to protect god's creation okay
i'm sorry but john kerry invoking god
does anyone believe that john kerry is
like
a deeply religious thinker this is how
he thinks of politics
i mean john kerry's been in politics for
years and years and years and years
this is trying to paper over radical
leftism with a veneer
of kind of sort of soft general
wonderful americanism right that's all
this is what he really means is now i'm
gonna get to go over to paris and hang
out with all my really close buddies and
talk in my
terrible french accent and uh and maybe
i'll have some nice wine and then i'll
sign away
half of america's economic freedom sound
good guys sound good
according to the washington post
everybody's excited dino granzoni with
alexa ellerberg
biden sends signal he is serious about
climate change with john kerry peck
the president's elect is tapping john
kerry the former secretary of state and
the democratic party's 2004 presidential
nominee to be as presidential
climate envoy the campaign announced on
monday installing the senior statesman
into the newly created position gives it
gravitas ooh
gravitas we're back to gravitas i don't
know if you
remember all the way back to 2000 in
2000 the rip on george w bush is that he
lacked gravitas
but al gore al gore captain chakras over
here
or the guy who is with the masseuse with
the shot in any case that may be old
news
for all of you but man bear pig al gore
al gore he was just he was
weighted down with all of his gravitas
john kerry has gravitas
which if if you believe that then i have
a ponzi scheme i'd like to uh i'd like
to talk to you about
so apparently according to the
washington post installing the senior
statesman into the newly created
position gives it gravitas
at a time when u.s credibility brought
on global warming and other issues has
waned
under president trump the move also
marks the first time the national
security council the main white house
body for setting foreign policy will
include someone dedicated
to climate change kerry tweeted on
monday the work we begin with the paris
agreement is far from done i'm returning
to government to get america back
on track to address the biggest
challenge of this generation
and those that will fall and then his
face collapsed in on himself
like like a mudslide in the beverly
hills in the hollywood hills
um let's just point out here that the
paris accords were complete jam
from the beginning they were a
non-binding commitment made by various
nations who did not keep up to those
commitments
they laid forth a series of steps that
would not have radically lowered the
climate over the course of the century
anyway
but they gave democrats something to
talk about having done when in fact they
actually did nothing
as the washington post sort of
quasi-admits under that 2015 accord
nearly 200 nations agreed to set their
own
non-binding targets non-binding
non-binding that would be the word there
okay i now make a non-binding pledge to
you i'm gonna give away all my money
hey guess what i'm not gonna do that
because it was non-binding that funny
see how that worked it was non-binding
they had their own non-binding targets
for cutting emissions
the success of the agreement relies on
how well u.s diplomats such as kerry can
wield
soft power to convince china india and
other nations to curtail emissions
as they grow their economies um given
john kerry's record on soft power the
answer is
really really poorly really poorly okay
so but
they're really happy again john kerry is
back guys and everybody is so excited
i mean aoc is excited bernie sanders is
super excited
the folks over at the sunrise movement
are really really excited
those are the crazy people who
approached dianne feinstein and tried to
lecture her about climate legislation
and she was like who are these stupid
kids and why are they in my office
and so that's exciting stuff meanwhile
the oh the the
supposedly incoming biden administration
is going to
be pushing for quote-unquote anti-racist
policy as well
which is to say in an overt attempt to
twist american law
in order to violate basic american
precepts in the name of
equality of outcome what other sort of
policy can we expect from a biden
administration
according to politico politico is now
pushing in politico magazine
a piece by sheryl cashion she's a law
professor at georgetown
and she suggests it's time for new
anti-racist policy now we've as we've
discussed before on the program
anti-racist
does not mean against racism in the
power lands of the left anti-racist
policy means
that you get rid of any policy that does
not result in equal outcome
not equal opportunity not equal access
to rights equal outcome
for various racial groups and what this
actually means is discrimination
under american law and badly formed
policy designed to subsidize
particular people of particular races at
the expense of other people of
particular races
and sheryl cashion is eager to push
forward the notion that
a new democratic coalition is on the
rise what's that coalition look like
well it is the
obama coalition of course that obama
coalition was not a broadcasting
coalition
attempting to appeal to people across
the spectrum it was a coalition
specifically designed to go at woke
white women college students
and minorities that was obama's entire
2012 pitch it's the reason why he lost
three and a half million votes from 2008
to 2012 he lost with virtually every
demographic group
votes in 2012 he still won the election
because he was able to turn out the base
and because he was able to motivate a
sort of intersectional coalition to win
democrats think that is the future and
so they want to double down on that in
policy
cheryl cashion says sizable majorities
of blacks hispanics asians and other
minority groups
still vote democratic a sizable majority
of white americans vote republican while
no racial or ethnic group is a monolith
partisan identity still has much to do
with attitudes about race
white democrats are more likely than
white republicans to acknowledge
systemic racial discrimination against
black people
while white conservatives are more
likely to perceive discrimination
against themselves than to acknowledge
racial discrimination
against blacks so she is basically
suggesting that white people
are instead resentful they're racially
resentful and so biden needs to forget
those racially resentful white people
who may oppose things like affirmative
action
instead she says a more viable strategy
for progressives than trying to win over
trump's supporters right away
would be to continue to win elections
powered by energized majorities
of black americans in critical states in
coalitions with other
energized people of color rightfully
taking their place in american politics
and the critical mass of whites willing
to see and resist racism
as biden implicitly acknowledged in his
victory speech the democratic party
cannot win a governing majority which
now hinges on two senate runoff races in
georgia without speaking authentically
to
and actually redressing the burdens and
aspirations of black people so what
exactly
does that look like what exactly does
that look like
well with democratic control of both
chambers as cheryl cashion and politico
an unshackled congress could abolish
anti-black policies and processes the
federal government set in motion
and repair continuing damage what would
that look like well
it would look like a 60 billion dollar
investment in communities hit hardest by
cover 19
could be financed by repealing tax
breaks for large corporations included
in the first federal coveted 19 relief
package so instead of giving
money to companies to keep people
employed instead you should directly
invest in areas that are heavily
minority that's what she's talking about
right she says new investments should be
allocated to black
communities bolder still congress could
atone for the federal legacy of
promoting segregation by enacting a law
that bans exclusionary zoning now
normally exclusionary zoning used to
refer to
zoning practices that said you cannot be
a black person in love in this area
that is against the federal constitution
of the united states
it also happens to be violative of the
civil rights act it's been federally
illegal for half a century
thank god okay well that's not what
she's talking about when she talks about
exclusionary zoning
she means getting rid of local laws that
privilege single-family homes and
exclude
denser affordable housing so in other
words she wants to have a federal law
that prevents you you're living in a
single-family home suburb
right racially diverse doesn't matter
she wants the person
the developer to be able to come in buy
four single-family homes directly next
door to you knock down all of the homes
and build
a low-income apartment complex that
might change your quality of life
regardless of who is actually occupying
those apartments but she says
that because in her view minority people
are inherently poor
this means that this will be helpful to
minorities is getting rid of all of
those local land use regulations at the
federal level
also she suggests that congress could
condition federal infrastructure
or other spending on measurable local
progress in creating affordable housing
in high opportunity areas as though
people don't then make the decision to
leave those areas and move to other
areas
right biden's already promised to back
similar legislation
also they want to apply a formula across
all federal programs to ensure targeted
spending
in census tracts with persistent poverty
okay again here she is
if we're talking persistent poverty in
white communities and like white
appalachia in white appalachia
she wouldn't be talking about this what
she really means is trying to
inject money into impoverished black
communities as an attempt to get those
people to vote democratic
and of course this will all be paid for
by repealing tax cuts for the people who
actually pay all the taxes in the
country
on the top end of the tax spectrum the
great lie of the democratic party has
always been
that people at the top end of the income
spectrum in the united states don't pay
their fair share of taxes
that of course is a complete lie people
at the top end of the income spectrum in
the united states pay
virtually all net taxes in the united
states because they don't receive
benefits back
from the federal government okay so
that's the sort of radical policy you
can look forward to
if the democrats were to take control of
the senate and if joe biden is
inaugurated
right that is that is what you can look
forward to and the media are there for
it man and here's the thing
what the media are going to tell you and
this is the really critical point what
the media are going to tell you is that
all of this is uncontroversial
this is the part where you're going to
go quietly nuts over the course of the
next several years or maybe not so
quietly nuts
it's the reason the media got trump in
2016. the reason is the media more than
any other force in american life have
lied to you and they have denigrated you
the media are trotting out all of these
radicals john kerry is a radical jake
sullivan is a radical
tony blinken is a foreign policy blob
member
it doesn't mean he's a radical he's just
wrong about everything they're gonna
trot forward all of these people and all
these radical policies as completely
non-radical
natural responses to the world around
you and these are not these are
perfectly in line with reason and
decency and if you oppose them it's
because you are against reason and
decency this is the line barack obama
used for eight long years and the media
simply mirrored it
the media ignored everything that barack
obama did to violate the constitution
and there was plenty there
they ignored the fact that he
militarized wings of the federal
government against his political
opponents
they ignored the fact that he spied on
journalists they ignored all of that and
then they told you that he had no
scandals his only scandal is that he
wore a tan suited press conference by
the way that happened to be the press
conference where he declared that isis
was dead shortly before isis was revived
i know everybody likes to ignore that
part okay but the media
are going to drive you up a wall which
is why you need to cut the cord and stop
subscribing to them and find different
alternative modes of communication
because that is what is coming next
your media are lying to you you're
they're lying to you
and they're going to tell you that
everything they say is a matter of fact
as opposed to a matter of opinion
that's the biggest lie of all it's not
just that they lie about policy and say
it's effective when it isn't although
they do that
it is that the media are telling you the
biggest lie which is they are lying to
you about who they are
and about who you are they are saying
that they are reasonable
objective voices and you for not
agreeing with them are an unreasonable
partisan hack
that is untrue i'm going to show you
proof of the media doing just that
in one second first let us talk about
the fact that if you've ever tried tommy
john underwear these are like the
they're the best they're the best
underwear on the market bar none i've
thrown out all
of my other underwear i only wear tommy
john my wife has thrown out all of her
stuff and she's gotten only tommy john
this black friday you can fight cold
with cozy
in tommy john underwear loungewear
pajamas and bras shop their black friday
sale right now
give the gift of comfort to everyone on
your list and yourself with tommy john
men's and women's loungewear
say goodbye to those old stained
sweatpants tommy john lounge where it is
luxuriously soft guaranteed to fit
perfectly
the same level of comfort and innovation
that goes into everything tommy john
makes
i mean i love the tommy john loungewear
it's basically my sabbath garb when i'm
not
in synagogue plus tommy john's
loungewear pajamas and underwear they
come in limited edition sets perfect for
giving but they sell out quickly
so order soon you don't really think
about your underwear and everyday life
but
you should because i mean those are on
your butt like all day long and you want
them to be comfortable there is no risk
with tommy john's best pair you'll ever
wear or it's free guarantee
shop tommy john's black friday sale
right now to make sure your gifts arrive
by the holidays go to tommyjohn.com
ben for 20 off site wide get 20 off for
a limited time only at tommyjohn.com
that is tommyjohn.com ben see site for
details okay so
as i mentioned the great lie the media
have been telling you for years to lie
about you and a lie about themselves the
lie about themselves that their
objective the lie about you is that
you're a partisan
if you disagree with them and so they're
just going to go right back to this
method of informational dis distribution
they are going to go back to performing
illicit services for democrats
they're going to go right back to
turning their uh
turning their entire profession into the
democratic massage parlor
that is what they're going to do and
it's not just the the so-called
objective journalists it's also your
comedians right comedians
used to come with the patina of
objectivity johnny carson famously did
not give away he was a democrat he
famously did not give away
his own political positions on things
things he said would undermine his
ability to do comedy jay leno did the
same thing
now you have overt hats like stephen
colbert who's essentially
a spartacus club socialist from college
talking about politics in the most
sycophantic possible way but he's
he's a comedian guys so that means we
have to take him with a certain grain of
salt here is stephen colbert he's not
even the best example i'm just going to
give this because it's the best example
of somebody
desperately seeking to perform a list of
services on behalf of democrats so
barack obama's on his book tour right
now and that means the entire media
has kicked into gear to go back to the
halcyon obama era when they could sit
around
and massage barack obama's shoulders as
he told them that he was going to
prosecute them for treason in any case
he was stephen colbert
last night i mean this is just
sycophantic drooling nonsense
can we just just take a moment can i
just i don't and i want to talk i just i
just want to take a moment to
to drink you in for just a moment
because
i'm having to get used to looking at a
president
again you know i've gotten out of i've
gotten out of the habit you got
i gotta warm up for joe biden i don't
wanna pull anything when i see him take
the oath of office
you gotta ease me into this a little bit
but then they're your actual objective
journalists right people like
yamiche alcindor so yamiche alcindor has
a long history
of being a partisan hack she is a
correspondent for
pbs newshour and a political contributor
to nbc news and msnbc she worked as a
reporter for both usa today
and the new york times now when donald
trump said that she was a political hack
the entire media and journalistic
establishment came to her she's an
amazing reporter
amazing amazing reporter here is your
very journalism objective journalist
being so objective in her journalism
and the journalism is going to get
absolutely everywhere she talks about
the glories of
of joe biden's cabinet i was talking to
a democrat
who just said this also felt like the
avengers it felt like we're being
rescued from this
this craziness that we've all lived
through from the last four years and now
here are the superheroes to come and
save us all oh they're like the avengers
guys that's objective journalism
has at its finest the avengers which
presumably means that they will uh which
which they'll break lots of things and
then everybody will cheer
right that's what the democratic
avengers they're here to do they're like
superheroes now
i'm not sure how you objectively cover a
superhero or a person you think is a
superhero but yamiche alcindor thinks
these people are superheroes and there's
nicole wallace just nodding along and
they're funny and that great yeah
they're all superheroes your objective
journalists
andrea mitchell she comes out and says
biden's not political
that's the thing about jobiden is he's
not political he literally
is the guy who suggested that mitt
romney was going to put black people
back in chains
he was a moving force behind the
implementation of obamacare
he was the first major american
politician to publicly support same-sex
marriage
he has spent his career borking people
he went after robert bork he went after
clarence thomas
joe biden is the definition of a
political animal he's been a politician
literally his entire adult life he was
elected to high office
at the age of 29. the hell is she
talking about but here's andrea mitchell
saying well you know here's the thing
he's really just like a non-political
guy
see the implication here is that if you
disagree it's because you're political
here's andrea mitchell very objective
news journalist for nbc news being very
objective in journalism
they are now being told that it is not
going to be political
and joe biden's saying these are people
this is a team who's going to tell me
this team will tell me what i need to
know what not what i want to know
that is a big change oh i mean this team
is not political
it's not a political team every one of
the people on that team has been a
longtime democratic hack
inside the inside the halls of
washington power the story is not biden
doing what biden is going to do because
biden is a democrat he is going to
appoint other democrats
the point here is that the media are
also democrats and
i i honest to god don't understand why
any incoming biden administration would
even need a press secretary
they don't need one they could literally
just have somebody from the
administration walk out
pick at random a member of the media
from the press pool have that person
stand behind the podium and just defend
the administration that day
that is what the media i mean andrea
mitchell has moderated presidential
debates
you know who else has martha raddatz so
martha raddatz came out and she said
his foreign policy team joe biden's
foreign policy team is not political
remember
martha raddatz has moderated
presidential debates
she claimed not a single member of
biden's foreign policy team was
political
that would include john kerry john
effing carey
jake sullivan and tony blinken
she i mean come on she she actually puts
john kerry aside she says when i look at
that group up there let's put john kerry
aside because he was the democratic
nominee but they're not political
they're just career people you know
career
because career people are never
political if you work in washington dc
your entire career you're no longer
political unless you're a republican
who's worked in washington dc your
entire career in which case you're
obviously a terrible person
but here is here's martha raditz doing
the work for the democrats
this is about the least flashy team you
could possibly get
they are deeply experienced uh they are
humble and they are lifelong public
servants
when i look at that group up there and
let's put john kerry aside because as we
know he was the democratic nominee for
president once
but they are not political they are just
career
people and as they say they really
do reflect america so is it any shock
then to learn
that there is this giant revolving door
between the media
and the biden administration ash scale
over at daily wire details this she says
for four years cnn and msnbc msnbc
decried the revolving door between the
trump administration and fox news
now analysts and contributors from those
networks are joining joe biden's
transition team in administration
for starters biden's pick for secretary
of state tony blanken worked as a global
affairs analyst for cnn
after serving as deputy national
security advisor for obama between 2013
and 2015.
lincoln also worked for bill clinton's
administration in the state department
jen
sackey just left the cnn payroll as a
commentator to join the biden transition
team as a senior advisor
before that she worked as the
spokesperson for the state department
under obama and then as white house
communications director
nbc news and msnbc have even more
analysts headed to team biden including
dr
ezekiel emanuel he's the former chicago
mayor rahm emanuel's brother and the
chief of staff
to obama emanuel will be guiding at
biden's covenant 19 response
barbara mcquade a legal analyst for nbc
and msnbc will join the biden transition
as part of the justice department
review team she previously served as u.s
attorney for eastern district of
michigan under obama richard stengel
a political analyst for nbc and msnbc
who by the way is
just awful i mean richard stengel has
been wrong on every major political
issue he has ever covered
single is a disaster area he's been
tapped as biden transitions
team lead for the u.s agency for global
media he wrote an op-ed in 2019
for the washington post as you'll recall
we talked about it at length last year
in which he called for free speech to be
restricted i'm so glad he is
representing
america with regards to the global media
in the biden administration
he wrote in that in that piece quote all
speech is not equal where truth cannot
drive out lies we must add new guard
rails i'm all for protecting thought we
hate but not speech that incites hate
and he suggested that perhaps he should
ban burning the quran or false lies
and narrow false narratives and lies on
social media
how about korean gin pierre she's a
jean-pierre she's a political analyst
for nbc and msnbc she left the network
in may to work on biden's campaign
before she joined kamala harris as her
chief of staff and then there's john
meacham presidential historian msnbc
contributor who failed to disclose to
the network that he was writing speeches
for biden during the campaign
and then went on air and talked about
how wonderful the speeches were that joe
biden had just given
the revolving door between the media and
the democrats is not a coincidence
because the media
and the democrats are a revolving door
they are just the same they're the same
there's no difference between gen saki
as the white house press communications
official and jen sackey is a commentator
on cnn it's the same john sackey
and cnn basically is just an outlet for
for joe biden but there's something more
important here there are two things that
are more important
one is the implication the media are
constantly drawing about themselves they
are objective and so when they say
that joe biden's team is apolitical and
professional
and expert and elite when they say it
it's objectively true
obj and you are a fool for not believing
them you're a partisan for not believing
them that's that's
point one point two is they then shut
the door behind them because the idea is
if they are the objective ones anyone
who disagrees with them
is not objective and is thus a purveyor
of quote-unquote fake news
and thus they should not be allowed to
disseminate their information
the objective media cadre are not
invested in the
in the viability of the first amendment
they're invested in their own viability
and
in curbing the first amendment to
prevent anybody from saying things they
don't like because of course
they are the expositors of truth while
everyone else is an expositor of lies
we'll get to that in just one moment
first
let us talk about how often it feels
like banking is years behind in terms of
technology
i mean we had a bank account a while ago
where we were still having to go into
the actual bank like the physical bank
and write checks in order to do basic
transactions we could go online
to do it well this is why you need aslo
aslo offers a free
business checking account with invoicing
bill pay no minimum balance requirements
no maintenance or overdraft fees instead
of the days it takes at a traditional
bank where you're still required to go
in person with aslo you just go to
azlo.com and you can apply in minutes
there's no waiting to use your account
with aslo's free instant funding feature
you can deposit up to a thousand bucks
and you can access it like
right now instantly now they've launched
the all new aslo pro bundle for only 10
bucks a month with tools like unlimited
envelopes to organize your money
discounted instant transfers and the
ability to set up recurring invoices
because you listen to this podcast you
can try aslo pro for free for 14 days
at aslo.com shapiro as those banking
services are provided by bbva usa
member fcic money magazine called as
load the quote
best business banking option for
freelancers and entrepreneurs
aslo's co-founder is one of fortune
magazine's latest 40 under 40.
go check out asl right now it's gonna
make your life it's gonna make your
banking a lot easier learn more with a
free copy of aslo's small business
starter guide or get started right now
and get an aslo pro
free 14 day trial at azlo.com that's
aslow.com no minimum deposit required
get started for free
at aslo.com shapiro go check them out
right now azlo.com
shapiro okay so so much of this
for the media are about me it's about
maintenance of their own position
they understand they do deep down they
have to understand that they've
completely blown up their credibility
that the american people do not trust
them and the american people should not
trust them
and so the way that they have posed
themselves is they have
increasingly come out of the closet as
members of the left but it destroys
their their their self-image to
acknowledge their own politics
it really does i'll give you just a
brief anecdotal example
so back during the 2012 republican
national convention was held down in
tampa
and i i was there and i remember i was
walking around the floor and the floor
of the convention is kind of a fun place
to be they have like a media row in the
media row
you have all of these kind of prominent
media people who are sitting in their
little booths broadcasting from the
convention
back in the days when we could all meet
together and at one of these booths at
the abc news booth was sam donaldson and
sam donaldson at that time was doing
like a 15-minute opinion piece
every day and i saw him walking around
and it occurred to me you know it's kind
of weird that sam donaldson is now doing
sort of quote uh opinion stuff given the
fact that for years he was the quote
unquote objective
journalist on abc right he was the guy
who people would go to he was a trusted
name in objective
news and so i went up to him and uh i
will say the man
as a man with magnificent eyebrows sam
donaldson puts me to shame that is a
dude with eyebrows so sam donaldson
uh i'm i was talking with him and i and
i said to him
yeah i'm i'm wondering sir if you have
the same opinions now that you had then
on politics and he said yes
and i said well do you think that maybe
your opinions shaped how you covered
politics
he said no and i said well i don't think
you're being honest because
frankly i think that your opinions do
shape your policies
do you think you're better than i am
yeah very angry you think you're better
than i am
and i said well i mean kind of i'll tell
you my biases and then i'll give you
what i think and then you can make a
decision
as to whether you believe me or not you
can take everything i say with a grain
of salt he got very very angry okay but
this is how members of the media think
they
they're like dolphins okay they have two
sides of their brain one is the
political side of their brain and one is
the objective journalism
side of their brain and they believe
that they can turn off one side in favor
of the other side and that is not true
it is not true at all okay some of them
are better at separating their objective
journalism
from their own political opinions but
most of them actually suck at it because
human beings
are have biases and those biases infuse
how they think very often unless they
have methodologies for thinking
like formalistic methodologies for
thinking as in law like originalism
unless they have actual methodologies
that you can follow a step-by-step
process to go from
point a to point b that is based on some
objectified metric of interpretation if
you don't have that
then basically they're just jumping from
point a to point b because point a and
point b are the same in their head
meaning their political view
and their opinion journalism are exactly
the same that is how you get to the
point where andrea mitchell
and martha raddatz are suggesting that
overtly political people are not
political because in their view
those people are not political see
they're just saying the truth they're
just saying what's true
this is why i don't think that media are
badly motivated i don't think that they
are
lying to you um in the sense that they
are they are purposefully trying to
prevaricate
i think that for them they actually
believe that their opinions are the
objective truth
they believe that the things they say
are objectively true
no matter whether those things are
opinion and they've been in the bubble
so long that nobody has ever disagreed
with them
and so they walk around all day long
thinking that they are the expositors of
capital t truth and anyone who disagrees
must be an expositor of falsehood and i
guess this gives them the justification
for doing what they are doing
right now which is attempting to slam
the door behind them
and when i say slam the door behind them
what i mean is that they are now
attempting to turn social media
into basically a bullhorn for their own
politics so the democrats turned the
media into a bullhorn for their politics
because the media is totally democratic
and then the media the your
establishment legacy media they decided
that facebook twitter youtube all these
places have to be turned into a bullhorn
for them because here's what happened
and it's very clear that this happened
from the data okay originally when the
internet sprung up
you could get the new york times on your
front doorstep you get the la times
a lot of people said i don't like what
i'm being provided here i think what i'm
being provided here is politically
biased and i'm being lied to
i don't agree that what these people are
presenting as quote unquote objective
truth actually represents objective
truth
i remember media bias in my family i
remember my first being aware of media
bias when i was about 12 years old and
my dad looked at the front page of the
la times in which they printed a photo
that was overtly false
of supposedly an israeli soldier beating
a palestinian man it turns out there was
an israeli soldier
who was actually defending in an israeli
man from being beaten by palestinians
they miscaptioned it the new york times
had run a correction okay the l.a times
picked up the same photo i remember my
father calling in and cancelling the l.a
times this is back in the 90s
okay but there weren't a lot of great
alternatives right if you're in l.a you
could get the daily news which was
a fine paper but it didn't have the same
sort of breadth and scope
as the l.a times because the other times
is much bigger and then the internet
cropped up
and you could easily cancel your
subscription you could easily
stop visiting these sources of supposed
news you could easily find alternative
sources of information
and so the internet opened up this whole
new vista of ways for people to get
information in fact that they had not
been provided
because the media engaged in selective
reporting there are several types of
media bias there is the
the media bias in which they simply do
not report facts they do not like and
then there's the media bias in which
they inject the facts they do like with
a particular shade
of coloring in order to receive in order
to achieve certain
outcomes and so what happened is that as
the internet came up
and matt grudge was the leader in this
as the internet came up suddenly
you could get news from places that were
not the la times without the filter
of pinch solsberger at the new york
times and people were into it
people were into it and then facebook
came along and facebook provided you an
easy way of getting all of that news an
easy way of networking with other people
who might think like you
an easy way of disseminating information
through channels
of like-minded people so you could
actually blow up news
it wasn't merely that you could find
news on some obscure website that the
media had refused to report
it was that you could actually you could
actually
allow your friends and family to see
those pieces of news quickly and easily
simply by sharing
and this is what facebook was this is
why people rushed to facebook because it
wasn't just about creating social
networks when it came to news
it was about finding also explicitly
about finding alternatives
to the mainstream media see if you
subscribe to the new york times or the
li times the boston globe or nbc
cbs abc you watch those on your basic
cable
or you watch those on network news if
you did all that you didn't need to be
on facebook for your news you already
had all that
it was for everybody else this is why
news sharing on facebook blew up because
there were so many
people who went to facebook specifically
to avoid
specifically to avoid the mainstream
media dominance of the space
and so this provided the impetus for
publications like ours daily wire to
begin
and garner hundreds of millions of views
over the course of like a single month
right this is what allowed other
right-wing outlets to start to thrive
specifically because again if you wanted
to view the new york times or any any of
the legacy media you knew about them if
you wanted other sources of information
you needed a platform
where you could view those other sources
of information and facebook made it
quick and made it easy
well now the establishment and legacy
media because they believe that they are
the sole expositors of truth they have
decided they are going to
curb social media they're going to
attack social media until social media
refuses to allow you to see the stuff
you went on facebook to see in the first
place
and facebook because now apparently
they're they're
being controlled from the inside by
their woke staffers and craven politicos
now because of that you're starting to
see social media curb their own
your ability to access the information
you went there to see in the first place
and they're doing so at the behest
of a pathetic self-indulgent media
firmly convinced of their own virtue
we're gonna get to more of this
in just one second this is what it's
gonna be like for years by the way it's
gonna be like this for years
this is the battle i've been saying this
for months now this is the battle
it's been obviously the battle since the
hunter biden shut down this is the
battle
will you even get to see will you even
get to access the information you want
to see
will you be able to fight back against
the misinformation put out by the left
if the left controls all the sources of
informational dissemination we're gonna
get to more of this in just one second
first
let us talk about how you protect
yourself from malware so if you've ever
been hit with ransomware it's like a
nightmare somebody hacks your computer
they lock up all your files they try to
make you pay them to unlock all of those
files
and it's not just ransomware there's all
sorts of malware if it hits your
computer rex not just your day it could
wreck your week or month
directly or year depending on what kind
of files you lose pcmatic is a next
generation antivirus designed to stop
modern threats like ransomware
independent testing from av tests just
named pcmatic a top performer in the
cyber security industry
giving it the best performance award for
2019. only pcmatic has american research
development and support
pcmatic's competition is foreign made
often in countries where malware
originates
pcmatic blocks annoying and malicious
ads for hassle-free web browsing and
makes your computer faster and more
reliable
even after years of use pcmatic protects
windows computers including
xp vista windows 7 8 and 10 windows
servers mac macbooks and android phones
and tablets
pcmatic is just 50 bucks for five
devices for one year with a full 30-day
money-back guarantee
if you act right now pcmatic has offered
my listeners a daily a free month of
security protection
with the purchase of an annual license
to access this offer head on over to
pcmatic.com
that is pcmatic.com to get world-class
security that keeps your computer
running great okay we'll get to more of
all this in a moment first thanksgiving
is almost here that means black friday
is almost here guys almost here since
last year's black friday deal
we've been consistently adding more
features and products to our membership
program
we are really pumped up about it to name
just a few things we've added much more
exclusive readers past content
our insider and above members can now
stream our content on apple tv and roku
that's exciting because of all the new
content we're adding like the michael
knowles show that's going five days a
week starting friday december 4th
your account also now comes with custom
badges you can earn by participating in
daily wire events
if you're an all access member you get
to join all access live are exclusive at
daily live streams with me or one of the
other hosts where you talk directly with
you about well
anything you want you can ask us any
sort of bizarre question we are likely
to answer it for you you also get two
leftist years tumblers
early access to our daily wear merch
daily discussions with our writers and
special guests
also we're continuing to add new
features and products the entire prageru
library that's currently being added to
the website
and candace owns is joining us early
next year with a pretty special show we
can't wait to announce more details
about that
needless to say we are excited about
this year's deal you're not going to
want to miss it so make sure that you
stay tuned in for the black
friday deal you're listening to the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
okay so the media's goal here is now to
re-establish their dominance
top down because the social media
companies they took you in they said
that you had a platform now where you
could see stuff that was not the
mainstream media again
the mainstream media dominated the space
they didn't need the social media
companies the social media companies
were explicitly
an alternative to those mainstream media
companies now the mainstream media
legacy media companies they are
attempting to use social media in order
to shut down the debate again
right they drew you in and now they are
shutting the door they're shutting the
door and they're making sure that you
don't see anything that they don't want
you to see
and they are laundering their
information in order to do so so what
they have basically declared
is that facebook for example should shut
down any right-wing site
so the way they do this is they actually
just go in very often and they falsify
information
people on left will just go in and
falsify information so what they'll do
is they'll do things like this they'll
go to
newsguard which is a pathetic site which
is designed to
basically say that anybody on the right
is disinformation if you say you're
overtly conservative they say that you
are
not a trusted news source if you are if
you are covertly
leftist right if you're the new york
times and you're pretty overtly leftist
but you try to pretend that you're not
then you're a trusted news source if
you're the daily wire
and we just say we're conservative
newsguard will literally say to us that
we are not a trusted news source because
we are more honest about our own
political biases than
the new york times and so newsguard will
then be used by facebook in order to
shut down
our traffic right you will see that you
will see people on the left
suggest that we at the daily wire were
disinformation why well they'll go over
to
wikipedia and they will actually use a
sentence in our wikipedia profile
inserted by a partisan leftist that does
not reflect reality in any way
right right now the wikipedia profile
literally reads many of the website's
story involve unverified information and
maybe considered fake news they can link
to a story that does not say anything
like that
there's nothing in the story that even
alleges that doesn't matter
so before the election this is not a
shock and here they are here are your
journalistic tech activists okay they're
not journalists they're activists they
are the
the tip of the spear in terms of trying
to get social media to shut down
dissemination of all information that
doesn't come from the new york times
kevin roose who spends every day trying
to get facebook to shut down traffic to
places like daily wire
or the federalist or breitbart or the
blaze or any place that he disagrees
with
he has a piece today with mike isaac and
shira frankel saying facebook struggles
to balance civility
and growth civility and growth by
civility they mean that they just want
you not to be able to see any
information that is not from the new
york times
in the 10 days after the presidential
election a team of facebook employees
presented the chief executive mark
zuckerberg with an alarming finding
election-related misinformation was
going viral on the site president trump
was already casting the election as
rigged
stories from right-wing media outlets
with false and misleading claims about
discarded ballots
miscounted votes and skewed tallies were
among the most popular news stories on
the platform now
note the reason that a lot of those
stories were popular on the platform is
because the new york times refused to
report many of them
and a lot of them were true kevin roose
himself has said this
okay we reported election irregularities
in michigan
okay and it was a true story kevin ruth
suggested that it was a false story
openly on twitter and now he's writing a
story about how facebook needs to shut
down
those sorts of stories even though he
acknowledged the story was true on
twitter
the employees proposed an emergency
change to the news to the site's
newsfeed algorithm
which helps determine what more than 2
billion people see every day
it involves emphasizing the importance
of what facebook calls news ecosystem
quality scores or neq
a secret internal ranking it assigns to
news publishers based on signals about
the quality of their journalism
typically neq scores play a minor role
in determining what appears on user
feeds but several days after the
election
zuckerberg agreed to increase the weight
that facebook's algorithm gave to any
queue scores to make sure authoritative
news appeared more prominently
said three people with knowledge of the
decision who were authorized not to
discuss
internal deliberations the change was
part of the break glass plans facebook
had spent months developing for the
aftermath of a contested election
it resulted in wait for it wait for it
wait for it a spike invisibility for big
mainstream publishers like cnn
the new york times and npr while posts
from highly engaged hyper partisan pages
such as breitbart and occupy democrats
became less visible
the employees said it was a vision of
what a calmer less divisive facebook
might look like
some employees argue that change should
become permanent even if it was unclear
how that might affect the amount of time
people spent
on facebook in an employee meeting the
week after the election workers asked
whether the nicer news feed could stay
said two people who attended first of
all zuckerberg is in control of his
company or if he is controlled maybe
he's not if he is control of his company
this would be about the damn time for
him to turn to his employees and say why
do i care what you think of the nicer
news algorithm
you are not the great arbiter of what
truth constitutes and by the way
for the new york times to say that their
program that they've been pushing
results in a spike in visibility for
them means they boosted their own
traffic
by basically hijacking the levers of
power at facebook via their staffers
cnn the new york times and npr oh
massive publications with huge
100 million dollar budget all of them
got bigger
meanwhile any alternative source of
information was blocked
shocker shocker guy rose in a facebook
executive said that the plan was meant
to be temporary
but apparently there are many people on
facebook who want to see it
not be temporary instead they would like
to see facebook continue
to boost only information that they like
and denigrate all of the information
that they don't like this is all part of
the plan
for the radical journalistic left they
pretend they are objective
if you don't agree with them it's
because you're bad and the social media
feeds should only reflect real news like
the new york times
and npr and cnn give me an effing break
and that's what you're going to be
dealing with under a biden
administration a media
the praetorian guard for joe biden the
praetorian guard for democrats
every republican will be castigated as
evil and malevolent and satanic
that is where all of this is going so
get ready the lid is going to clamp down
on your ability to get information
that's why you should go subscribe to
your favorite publications right now
before it is too late
alrighty so speaking of this
the media have as i said been in a
long-running battle to basically shut
down
all methods of information that allow
you to see alternative sources
the the staffers at a variety of
different outlets for determination of
information
they have been very vocal in their
attempts to shut down that dissemination
of information so as i've been saying
facebook itself had an algorithm that
had put into place that boosted the new
york times cnn and npr in the aftermath
of the election we know for a fact that
they shut down our traffic
like probably three weeks before the
election we could see it in the actual
metrics
over at daily wire and the new york
times continues to push this day in
and day out you do not deserve to see
information that charlie warsell and
kevin roose
and kara swisher at the new york times
don't want you to see you should only
see the information they want you to see
see this is the difference between folks
on the left and folks on the right i
have never
not once told you that there should be
some attempt to shut down
cnn npr new york times cbs abc np
i've never said that not once i said you
might want to cut your cable because
they're lying to you
because they are but i have never said i
have never said
that there should be an attempt by any
overt authority
any major social media platform to shut
down systems of informational
dissemination
that i don't like i've never said cnn
new york times should be downgraded in
terms of their ability to have reach
on facebook's platform i've never said
anything remotely like that in fact
when it comes to people asking me what
sources of information they should view
the truth is i don't even tell them not
to read the new york times i tell them
they shouldn't subscribe
but that's because you shouldn't fund
people who are who are overtly against
you and don't like you very much but
i've always said
when people say what do you read i'll
tell you i read the new york times the
washington post
i'll tell you that i read alternative
sources of information ranging from the
daily wire to the washington examiner to
the federalist and all the rest
and when people ask what sort of podcast
should i listen to i've always told them
listen to my podcast then listen to pod
save america
and then decide which one of us you
think is being more honest decide where
you think you come down on various
issues
folks on the left won't do that to folks
on the left it is anathema to allow you
to listen to alternative points of view
it is very bad for them to allow you to
listen to alternative points of view
in fact if a left-wing host were ever to
suggest that you might give a listen to
my show
they would be run out of town by their
own supporters they'd be running out of
town on a rail
i say to my listeners all the time that
you should listen to alternative sources
of information other than mine
i've had on this show many times people
on the left on our sunday special we
routinely feature guests who disagree
with us
the same simply does not hold true for
many members of the left and this is why
you see pieces like this one from
charlie warzell another one of
the the informational shutdown advocates
of the new york times what facebook fed
the baby boomers many americans feeds
are nightmares i know because i spent
weeks living inside two of them well
clearly charlie warzell should
police what kind of feed you have on
your facebook he said in mid-october i
asked two people i'd never met to give
me their facebook account password for
three weeks
leading up to election day i wanted to
immerse myself in the feeds of a type of
person who's become a trope of sorts in
our national discussion about politics
and disinformation
baby boomers with an attachment to
polarizing social media by the way we
should analyze the word disinformation
here
okay misinformation is over at falsehood
disinformation
generally speaking used to refer to an
overt psychological campaign waged by
a place like the soviet union in order
to push false narratives about america
if we're speaking about this information
in that way the main the mainstream
media engage in disinformation campaigns
and tactics far more often
than people in the right wing okay the
mainstream media have have
sold the the lie that america was rooted
in racism and bigotry
and continues to be the home of racism
and bigotry
the mainstream media has sold the lie
that donald trump was a russian
collusion actor okay that's
disinformation and in the case of that
particular story that was
actually russian edition information in
any case charlie juarez hell says
facebook is bad really you should just
read the new york times because i went
looking for older americans not
full-blown conspiracy theorists trolls
or partisan activists whose news
consumption has increased sharply in the
last
few years on facebook neither of the two
people i settled on describe themselves
as partisan
both bemoan the toxicity of our politics
here's a sample a set of adoring
grandparents posing with rosy cheeked
babies mimi and pop-pop's first visit
since march the post reads
next a meme for joe biden's of joe biden
next to a photoshop for sale sign
for more information contact hunter the
sign reads after that as opposed to
advertising a funny rude metal sign
displaying a unicorn in a tutu giving
the middle finger
thought of you the post reads below that
is a screenshot of a meme created by the
pro-trump group turning point usa
your city on socialism the post reads
displaying a series of photos of
abandoned buildings empty grocery
store shelves and bleeding men in
makeshift dirty hospital beds
the feed goes on like this an infinite
scroll of of contents without context ah
you need context for socialism being
awesome guys that's really what you need
and you need context
for memes now we need to contextualize
memes
now perhaps charlie warazel doesn't
understand how the internet works but
memes exist on both the right and the
left and they're quite popular on all
sides
specifically because they're basically
the junk food of informational
dissemination
but he says touching family moments are
interspersed with bible quotes that look
like hallmark cars
cards hyper partisan fear-mongering and
conspiratorial misinformation
the the feat is in a word a nightmare i
know because i spent the last three
weeks
living inside it okay i'm sorry this is
just
a joke it's a joke charlie warzell
thinks that this is a nightmare because
charlie warazel doesn't like what he's
reading
that's the end of the story and this is
the way that so many on the left think
they think i don't like what other
people are reading therefore i should be
in control of what other people are
reading
therefore i should try to prevent other
people from reading the things i don't
want them to read
and this is how you end up with the
ridiculous
story that we saw break yesterday about
penguin penguin
random house staffers trying to get
jordan peterson's book canceled okay so
jordan peterson's book
his last book 12 rules for life which is
great you should read it
jordan's a friend it's it's i'm i love
jordan jordan's a really really good guy
jordan's book sold three million copies
three million copies how many crappy
woke books that sold five thousand
copies jordan peterson's book supported
you know how much money the publisher
made off of jordan peterson's good book
so they could publish a bunch of woke
crap that sold seven copies
okay a lot of those books got published
because jordan peterson exists
apparently according to vice world news
several penguin random house canada
employees
confronted management about the
company's decision to publish a new book
by controversial canadian psychologist
jordan peterson at an emotional town
hall on monday
dozens more have filed anonymous
complaints
okay so like so what i'm i'm
so tired of companies being run by the
peons
because it's not how this works i run a
company we love our staffers
we love them so much that we pay them
and we support them and we provide them
as employees with the insurance to which
they are entitled
and if they tried to run the editorial
on this site if they tried to tell me
how editorial should be run here
they would be fired and they would find
themselves unemployed
the idea that they would come to me
crying crying about a decision to
publish
jordan peterson is unthinkable and
unthinkably stupid
it's ridiculous and yet it's taken
seriously in the halls of corporate
power because they are so
unwilling to defend the first amendment
and broadness of speech protections that
they won't stand up for their own values
it's all about the sensitivity of their
own employees as though there aren't 10
employees waiting to get in the door
in the middle of a global pandemic to
work at a publishing house
on monday penguin random house canada
canada's largest book publisher and a
subsidiary of penguin random house
announced we'll be publishing beyond
order
12 more rules for life by peterson will
be released in march 2021.
the book will be published by portfolio
in the us and penguin press in the uk
both part of the penguin random house
empire four penguin random house canada
employees who did not want to be named
due to concerns over their employment
well good they should be concerned
said the company held a town hall about
the book monday okay can i tell you
something we're never going to do at
this company hold the town hall
it's not going to happen if you got a
complaint you can come and talk to me
about it we are not holding town halls
we're not holding whining
grievance sessions not a thing that is
going to happen during which executives
defended the decision to publish
peterson while employees
cited their concerns about platforming
someone who is popular in far-right
circles
he's an icon of hate speech and
transphobia the fact he's an icon of
white supremacy regardless of the
content of his book i'm not proud to
work for a company that publishes him a
junior employee who is a member of the
lgbtq community and who attended this
town hall told
vice world news okay well um if you're
not proud to work there's the door enjoy
but they held the town hall anyway by
the way the idea that he's an icon of
hate speech and transphobia is absurd on
its face
i love that this employee says the fact
that he's an icon of white supremacy
regardless of the content of his book so
it doesn't matter if his book explicitly
denounces white supremacy
all that matters is that there are a
bunch of people i don't like who like
his book that means we should ban his
book let's just preemptively burn books
why not he hasn't even read the book but
let's preemptively burn the thing
and another employee said people were
crying in the meeting about how jordan
peterson has affected their lives
they said one co-worker discussed how
peterson had radicalized their father
another talked about how publishing the
book will negatively affect their
non-binary friend
the company since june has been doing
all these anti-racist and eldership
things and then publishing peterson's
book goes completely against this it
just makes all their previous efforts
seem completely performative
well okay spoiler alert guys their
efforts were completely performative
i mean i'm glad you're just noticing
this now but um yeah all these
corporations they're doing performative
wokeness to shut you up
because your perspective is annoying to
them
they'll do it because they don't want
legal liability and they don't want
hr grievances but if it comes up between
here we could publish a book that's
going to sell three million copies and
you guys are going to a little bit
that's a pretty obvious decision but the
fact that this is even being taken
seriously speaks to the leftist
mentality that is not about free speech
and it is not
about any sort of diversity of thought
it is simply about
who gets to rule that is all
the penguin random house canada employee
said the company was secretive about
releasing the new book one said the
title didn't appear in an internal
database that normally includes
all future books the junior employee
said i feel it was deliberately hidden
and dropped on us once it was too late
to change course again
you have options one of those options is
not working there you can do it
i've done that before when i disagreed
with the publication i walked out the
door when i disagreed with breitbart in
2016 and how they handled the particular
controversy i left you can do it too
anytime you damn well please but you
have the courage of your convictions you
just want to take control of the company
itself
the apparently scott sellers director of
marketing strategy spoke about how the
company has to work with writers whose
views we quote
don't necessarily support but said
sellers also defended peterson by
stating he supports same-sex marriage
the implication being of course that if
peterson did not support same-sex
marriage they simply could not publish
the book it is ridiculous crap
but this sort of ridiculous crap extends
to every area of the american culture
like every area of the american culture
if you so much as wink
at people who do not think like you you
will be taken out to the woodshed
so let's take an example so there's a
new movie it's out on netflix it's
called hillbilly elegy i got to see an
early
viewing of the uh of the movie because
i'm a special person
it is the story of jd vance jd vance is
a columnist for national review he went
to yale law school elite served in the
military
and it's based on his book hillbilly
elegy right so hillbilly elegy sold a
bajillion copies
and the book was basically a story about
poverty culture in white appalachia it
was about how his family came from
kentucky
and how he grew up in impoverished in
formerly industrial areas of ohio
and how a culture of poverty contributes
to
drug use and to bad parenting and how in
order to break that cycle of poverty
very often you have to make deliberate
decisions to change how you have thought
about your life right that's what
hillary billiog is about and it's an
interesting socio-cultural study it
became sort of a dakota ring for a lot
of people in the media
about trump's america because they were
wondering why did all these rural white
people
vote for donald trump this new york real
estate mogul
like how did that happen and so
hillbilly elegy became kind of the
the way that they decoded that because
these were a lot of people who were
impoverished and these impoverished
people had been stuck in cycles of
poverty and donald trump promised them a
way forward and he promised them that he
was going to solve some of their
problems and he took them seriously
okay that was that was how hillbilly
elegy was viewed then there was a switch
a couple of years ago this book was
published in 2016. it was widely
heralded right left and center
okay then there was a there was a move
that happened probably 2017 2018 a
backlash against the book after trump
won
and the backlash went something like
this it was really threefold one was
hillbilly elegy is bad because it takes
white poverty seriously as we all know
poverty is a racial problem white white
poor people
are still beneficiaries of white
privilege so why are we even talking
about them that was point number one so
hillbilly elegiana's face was bad
because it talked about white poor
people and cultures of poverty
which suggested that perhaps cultures of
poverty have nothing to do with race and
the way to
break cycles of cultures of poverty is
to make individual decisions which cuts
against the intersectional
argument that all poverty is connected
with systemic racism and evil
and can only be broken by the system
itself being broken okay so that was
point number one against hillbilly elegy
put forward by the left
point number two is why are you even
taking these trump supporters seriously
because as we all know
they are bad people and then point
number three is that hillbilly elegy
is a simplistic view of the power of
individual decision making
and that we should never tell people
that they themselves have the capacity
to rise in america right so it was it
was sort of a three-fold attack on
hillbillyology and suddenly hillbilly
elegy went from being the darling book
of the critic circle
to being a whipping post for so many
leftist thing pieces okay so
in that glowing period where hillbilly
elegy was popular all the way across the
aisle they made a movie of it
okay and the movie features some of the
biggest stars in hollywood it's got
glenn close as mama
and it's got it's got amy adams
uh it's got amy adams playing jd vance's
mother
okay and the movie's good it's a good
movie okay the the movie
doesn't go into sort of all the socio
cultural stuff the socio-economic stuff
that the book does because a book is a
book and a movie is a movie but it is a
good well-told family story amy adams is
terrific in it i mean she's
physically transformed you can't
recognize her right amy adams is a very
beautiful woman
she plays somebody who's essentially
gone to seed uh and she's very good
glenn close plays mama and she's very
very good
the performances across the board are
universally quite good
the the script is inarguably apolitical
it is not a political script it is very
obviously not a political script
the the the critics have just savaged
this thing to death
they've savaged this thing to death and
the reason they savage this thing to
death is because when it was greenlit
it was considered a a sort of again
decoder ring for trump's america
and then after trump won it became an
evil book that was justifying the evils
of trump's america
so the atlantic for example has a has a
big piece by david sims called hillbilly
elegy is one of the worst
movies of the year the new netflix film
is a think piece trap shiny on the
outside
hollow on the inside everyone in this
world is one of three kinds declares
mama the wise grand matriarch of ron
howard's new film hillbilly elegy
a good terminator a bad terminator and
neutral i hate to correct mama who is
trying to encourage her impressionable
grandson jd vance to follow a righteous
path by invoking arnold schwarzenegger's
beloved
action franchise there is no such thing
as a neutral terminator these cyborg
heroes exist either protect or destroy
i cannot imagine what a neutral
terminator would do mama is entitled to
her bad movie opinions of course but
this monologue is the kind of
speechifying that rings hollow
throughout hillbilly elegy an adaptation
of jd vance's best-selling 2016 memoir
that debuts on netflix tomorrow
when it first arrived on bookshelves
vance's story was celebrated as a
glimpse into an oft-ignored pocket of
america the white working class of
appalachia and the rust belt who swung
to donald trump in the 2016 election
held as an angry translator and cited by
both hillary clinton and oprah winfrey
vance wrote about growing up poor living
with a heroin addicted mother and
clawing his way into harvard law school
the book arrived at a seemingly
serendipitous moment offering a bleak
but candid view of communities gutted by
drug abuse and poverty
hillbilly elegy the memoir has been
dissected challenged and eviscerated
it largely focuses on the virtues of
hard work and perseverance launching
vague broad size against the american
welfare system
the author often appears uninterested in
interrogating deeper systemic issues
right so you can see that
really the rip on the movie is going to
be a rip on the book jd vance happens to
be a republican we can't have a book
that makes a republican
a movie that makes a republican book
look good that can't be a thing
in adapting the book howard and the
screenwriter vanessa taylor have gone
even further stripping the text of
anything that might feel remotely
controversial or pointed
netflix's hillbilly elegy is an
oscar-friendly narrative of personal
triumph in the face of great hardship
a movie designed to end with an
uplifting epigraph it is also one of the
worst
movies of the year stuffed with a-list
stars and tearful monologues
it is a neutral terminator of a film
polished yet utterly inert
okay so again all that matters here is
that the
the basic movie is bad because jd vance
is bad because hillbilly elegy is bad
and this is how entertainment is going
to be treated i mean we know this we
know that the oscars are only going to
feature stories that the left likes
right you have to have
a particular protagonist or a particular
percentage of staffers or members of
particular sexual orientation or or
sexual
or racial minorities right every aspect
of your culture is going to be turned in
favor of the leftist narrative
and if hollywood danes to step out of
that narrative for like one single
second then make a movie like hillbilly
hillbilly elegy with big stars then ron
howard one of the biggest
democrats in hollywood will be
eviscerated by the media for it
that is the way this is going to go okay
the left has designs
on your your personal future on what you
can see
on the information you can consume they
have personal designs
on exactly how your kid is going to be
educated
john murakowski over at real clear
investigations has a piece
talking about anti-racist teaching in
k-12 schools targeting whiteness
he says the notices to parents began
arriving fast and furious in the weeks
after the death of george floyd in late
may
in dramatic urgent language k-12 schools
across the country both public and
private professed solidarity with black
lives matter and vowed to dismantle
white supremacy as they scrambled to
introduce anti-racist courses
and remake themselves into racism-free
zones the president of the lower marian
school board and on philadelphia's
affluent main line declared to families
we need to eradicate white supremacy and
heteropatriarchy in all of our
institutions
that's the lower middle that's the
marian school board
in maine a coastal public school
district where 3.7 of the students are
black or hispanic the superintendent
declared war on quote the intentional
barriers white people have built to harm
black people
the top administrator added we grieve
for all of the black lives taken by
white supremacy at brentwood college
school in la
they've made more changes to the
curriculum this year than any other in
the private school's
five-decade history teachers are
introducing critical race theory and
assigning readings
from garbage purveyor ibram kendy the
academic and author who contends race
neutral policies are the bulwark of the
white ethno state
for nation the nation's k-12 schools
have been incrementally adopting
multiculturalism and ethnic studies for
decades
but those courses were the exception not
the rule this summer's blm protests have
sparked new levels of commitment a
newfound urgency and a new trend
anti-racist pedagogy and if
administrators deliver on their promise
the sweeping changes will introduce new
courses
shift hiring priorities rebalance
student demographics redirect stipends
and scholarships and revise
conduct standards okay that is the way
the educational system is going to move
so prepare for it okay the biden era is
not going to be
in the era of great comedy and unity the
biden era is going to be an era in which
all informational dissemination systems
ranging from the educational
to hollywood to corporate america to
social media are going to
are going to be directed at you and your
values the fight is not ending right now
the fight is just beginning
so get on board or they're going to
throw you off the boat
well this brings us to the end of
today's podcast if you want two
additional hours check out our radio
show later today and subscribe at
dailywire.com so you don't have to pay
attention to a media that hates you
and wishes to eviscerate all of your
values otherwise have yourself a
wonderful thanksgiving weekend try to
relax a little bit we'll see you here
next monday i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
borin
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
production manager pavel wydowsky our
associate producers are nick sheehan and
rebecca doyle
the show is edited by adam scievent
audio is mixed by mike
coromina hair and makeup is by nico
geneva the ben shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20.
hey everybody it's andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
american republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon is
turned to blood
but on the andrew clavin show that's
where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the
apocalypse with me
andrew clayton
you